[Music]
i'm a fan of those sort of
do-it-yourself uh remodeling shows yeah
and i like those shows one of the
reasons i like it is because i'm kind of
handy myself you know i i know my way
around a toolbox
uh and i thought it would be kind of fun
if we could do something like that on
our show
and and renovate a room
in in the house of one of our staffers
oh yes so um our field producer and uh
well he's also a first-time homeowner uh
jason chalemi he has a bathroom that
needed a that's him that's not the
bathroom
uh
his bathroom needed a complete overhaul
we've got some pictures of it uh it's
just kind of you know it's like old and
and that was just like a weird grab bag
of wall tiles that they put on the floor
right uh you know everything was just
kind of crummy so it needed some
updating
and luckily the people at lowe's said
that they would help with the project
and they would provide us with whatever
materials we would need to do it
ourselves so jason and i went shopping
at lowe's and here's what happened oh
cool
[Music]
[Applause]
all right uh here we are at lowe's in
the um
fashion bath all right and we've got uh
somebody here to help us this is tom
how are you doing tom good to meet you
i'm amanda welcome to lowe's northridge
this is jason
where do you want to start first what
how about this toilet that flushes a
bucket of golf balls in a single flush
do you know many people who are golf
balls these days no no
we try to remedy that right off the bat
all right you can lay down there get
fully submerged get full therapeutic and
you can also operate as a normal bath
this is nice i'm getting jealous this is
too i'm not going to get to enjoy this
they can come over can i come over and
take a bath you can be the first one to
use it all right you got it one at a
time in there might be uh best at first
yeah yeah yeah um could you point out
oh like what the most expensive thing in
the store is um how about a refrigerator
but this is for a bathroom andy sure
this is for the bathroom
oh you're gonna put a refrigerator in
the bathroom it has the internet right
there why do you need the internet on
your refrigerator well you can just
order grocery ride once you open the
refrigerator to find out you're missing
some stuff twitter
and twitter on the fridge yes
finally yeah do you have a toilet that
tweets
not yet all right
five star flush power yeah all right
that's good in case you got any golf
balls you want to get rid of it's an
automatic drop seat so when you
walk away from the fixture when you go
to sit down the seat it releases all
right yeah no more seat slamming though
no more angry defecation for you
well thanks
guys your help bye-bye thanks
why am i pushing this you're right i'm
sorry
i don't know what this is but we should
probably get
[Applause]
you guys yeah
all right here we go we're ready with
the demolition
let's start tearing it apart
[Music]
you don't love me i don't love you
you're gonna want to fix that hole
goodbye toilet
here's where the toilet paper goes
[Music]
you know
i had three network sitcoms at one point
i was number one on the call sheet
three different times for two different
networks
man
i really had it made
then america rejected me
three times they said
that's enough richter for us
and here i am now
with my head under your sink
getting your water dripping on my face
i have a loving family though
that's something
yeah i mean i take solace in them
oh once or twice a year
when the medication allows
but really
i guess this is where i'm meant to be
right here
well let's get that sink out of there
[Applause]
ah
looking good yeah looking real good is
this what you had in mind
no
all right well listen
i gotta go
i got a lunch date with my agent
i'll check back after
lunch um
and i'm gonna leave you now all right
i'll be honest with the belt
um
it's what how many days later three four
days later yeah uh i have done some
pretty great work in there
uh yeah i sort of you know fell back on
some old skills
and i think you're really gonna like uh
what i've done with the place it's gonna
be a nice surprise
what do you think it's
amazing yes it's so much better it's uh
it's all the stuff that we picked out at
lowe's we got rid of that crappy floor
nice fixtures beautiful cabinet and some
nice uh wayne's cotting and then here
you come around here
get a shot of the looking back this way
and uh
yeah
oh who are these guys
uh that's ephram and daniel from dream
home remodeling they're actually the
contractors that did all the work
okay thanks guys
uh they roll on there
so anyway here it is your new dream bath
um if you'd like i'm gonna leave you
alone here with uh with gene and the
camera maybe uh
we can get a little uh footage of you
breaking it in for the web if you know
what i'm saying
all right all right thanks annie enjoy
thank you guys
nice job
it looks beautiful thank you thank you
no it was fun and uh we actually got
some extra stuff at lowe's um that i
kind of slammed together and look what i
made i made a brand new uh announcer's
podium announcer's podium
[Applause]
[Music]
watch this
oh that's not a fountain
that's beautiful
now
now we have a place to put grandma when
she visits
very nice work andy thank you very much